ласкаво просимо назад до курсу «Розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень» мене звати Джон Ватус, я технічний директор з освіти в IBM
Quantum це урок номер 15 серії і третій урок четвертого розділу, присвяченого квантовому виправленню
помилок до цього моменту ми розглянули кілька прикладів квантових кодів виправлення помилок, зокрема дев'ятикубітний код Шора
семикубітний код Стіна та п'ятикубітний код, а також обговорили формалізм стабілізаторів, який забезпечує
нам математичну основу для опису та аналізу цих та багатьох інших квантових кодів виправлення
помилок коди, які я щойно згадав, безсумнівно цікаві й являють собою природне місце для початку
вивчення квантового виправлення помилок проблема в тому, що вони можуть терпіти лише дуже низький рівень помилок
виправлення помилки на одному qubit із п'яти, семи або дев'яти — непогано, але, швидше за все, принаймні наскільки ми припускаємо
нам доведеться терпіти набагато більше помилок, щоб зробити крупномасштабні квантові обчислення
реальністю у цьому уроці ми вперше поглянемо на деякі складніші конструкції квантових кодів виправлення помилок, зокрема коди, які можуть
терпіти набагато вищий рівень помилок, ніж ті, що ми бачили досі, і розглядаються як перспективні кандидати для практичного квантового виправлення помилок у
реальних фізичних пристроях ось короткий огляд уроку ми почнемо з класу
квантових кодів виправлення помилок, відомих як CSS-коди, названих на честь дослідників, які їх відкрили: Роберта Колдербанка, Пітера
Шора та Ендрю Стіна конструкція CSS-коду дозволяє взяти певні пари класичних
кодів виправлення помилок та об'єднати їх у квантовий код виправлення помилок у межах цього обговорення ми
досить швидко розглянемо класичні лінійні коди, а також обговоримо деякі основні властивості CSS-
кодів друга частина уроку присвячена коду, відомому як торичний код, який є фундаментальним і справді
красивим прикладом квантового коду виправлення помилок, що може терпіти відносно високий рівень помилок фактично
торичний код — це не окремий приклад квантового коду виправлення помилок, а нескінченна сім'я кодів — один для
кожного натурального числа починаючи з двох і в останній частині уроку ми коротко розглянемо пару інших
сімей квантових кодів, зокрема поверхневі коди, які тісно пов'язані з торичним кодом, а також
кольорові коди люди вивчають класичні коди виправлення помилок із 1940-х років
і це захопливий і багатий предмет лінійні коди — мабуть, найпростіший тип класичного виправлення
помилок і я поясню точне значення слова «лінійний» у цьому контексті трохи пізніше, але один простий
спосіб пояснити, що вони собою являють, — це сказати, що вони є стабілізаторними кодами, які виявляються класичними, і незабаром ми побачимо, що
CSS-коди — це, по суті, пари класичних лінійних кодів, об'єднаних разом для створення квантового коду
виправлення помилок отже, заради цього обговорення нам потрібно розуміти кілька основних речей про
класичні лінійні коди спочатку ми візьмемо Σ як двійковий алфавіт для всього цього
обговорення і тепер, коли ми говоримо про класичний лінійний код, ми маємо на увазі множину C двійкових рядків довжини n для деякого
натурального числа n, яка задовольняє лише одній основній властивості: якщо u і v є двійковими рядками в C, то рядок
u XOR v також є в C до речі, u XOR v означає побітове «виключне або» u і v, як ми
бачили багато разів у п'ятому та шостому уроках у розділі квантових алгоритмів серії і саме це означає, що класичний
код є лінійним: по суті, ми думаємо про двійкові рядки довжини n як про n-вимірні вектори
де всі елементи або нуль, або одиниця, але замість звичайного додавання векторів над дійсними або комплексними
числами ми використовуємо додавання за модулем 2, що просто є XOR отже, якщо ми маємо
два кодових слова u і v, тобто u і v є двійковими рядками в C, тоді u плюс v за модулем 2, або інакше кажучи u XOR
v також має бути кодовим словом у C до речі, це твердження має бути вірним навіть якщо u дорівнює v нічого не забороняє
таку можливість і це означає, що кожен класичний лінійний код повинен містити рядок із самих нулів, оскільки
побітове XOR будь-якого рядка із самим собою є рядком із самих нулів наприклад, трибітний
код повторення є класичним лінійним кодом зокрема, є два можливих варіанти для u і два можливих
варіанти для v і досить тривіально перебрати можливі пари, щоб переконатися, що ми завжди отримуємо кодове слово при обчисленні побітового
XOR ось інший приклад, який називається (7,4,3) кодом Хеммінга це один із перших класичних кодів
виправлення помилок, який коли-небудь був відкритий, і він складається з 16 двійкових рядків довжини сім є дуже проста логіка
вибору цих рядків, але я не буду пояснювати її в цьому відео, і ще варто згадати, що іноді ці рядки записують у зворотньому порядку, але
зараз головне полягає в тому, що якщо ми візьмемо будь-які два рядки та обчислимо їх XOR, ми отримаємо інший рядок у
коді отже, це лінійний код, і позначення [7,4,3] у одиночних квадратних дужках означає щось аналогічне подвійним
квадратним дужкам, що я згадував у попередньому уроці для стабілізаторних кодів, але тут це для класичних лінійних
кодів зокрема, кодові слова мають сім бітів, є 16 кодових слів, тому ми можемо закодувати чотири біти за допомогою коду і
це код відстані три, тобто потрібно перевернути принаймні три біти будь-якого кодового слова, щоб отримати
інше кодове слово і це означає, що він може виправляти до однієї помилки перевернення біта ці прості приклади
кодів але навіть приклад коду [7,4,3] Хеммінга виглядає досить загадково, коли ми просто перераховуємо всі кодові слова, тому нам потрібні кращі способи
опису класичних лінійних кодів і є два природних способи зробити це один спосіб — описати класичні
лінійні коди, задавши мінімальний набір кодових слів, що породжують код, тобто взявши всі можливі
підмножини цих кодових слів і обчислюючи їх XOR ми отримаємо весь код і це виражається математично
тут на екрані інший спосіб думати про це — розглядати цей код як підпростір векторного простору і цей
набір породжуючих елементів є базисом для цього підпростору, пам'ятаючи, що це векторний простір, де арифметика виконується за модулем 2 якщо ми маємо m породжуючих елементів,
ми отримаємо код, що містить 2 у степені m елементів кожен породжуючий елемент подвоює кількість елементів у коді і
це узгоджується з фактом, що класичні лінійні коди над двійковим алфавітом завжди містять кількість рядків, що є степенем
двійки другий природний спосіб описати класичний лінійний код — через перевірки парності, зокрема це мінімальний
список двійкових рядків тієї самої довжини, що й рядки в коді, такий, що рядки в коді — це саме ті, чий двійковий
скалярний добуток із кожним із цих рядків перевірки парності дорівнює нулю, де двійковий скалярний добуток — це просто звичайний
WEBVTT
скалярний добуток за модулем 2, і це теж те, що ми зустрічали в уроці п'ять у контексті запитів до
алгоритмів причина, чому вони називаються рядками перевірки парності, полягає в тому, що заданий рядок u має двійковий добуток рівний
нулю з v тоді і лише тоді, коли біти u, що відповідають одиницям у v, мають парну
парність коли ми описуємо класичний лінійний код таким чином за допомогою мінімального списку рядків перевірки парності, кожний рядок
перевірки парності ділить кількість рядків у коді навпіл, тому для одного коду, описаного цими двома різними способами, ми завжди матимемо m + r = n
одна важлива річ, на яку варто звернути увагу: двійковий скалярний добуток — це не скалярний добуток у формальному сенсі і
зокрема, коли два рядки мають двійковий скалярний добуток рівний нулю, це не означає, що вони є ортогональними у звичному сенсі, в якому ми розуміємо
ортогональність наприклад, двійковий скалярний добуток рядка 11 із самим собою дорівнює нулю, тому можливо, що
один із цих рядків перевірки парності сам є в коді це просто те, що слід мати на
увазі наприклад, як ми вже знаємо, трибітний код повторення є лінійним кодом, тому його можна описати обома цими
способами зокрема, є лише один варіант породжуючого елемента, який підходить, і це 111, і ми можемо альтернативно описати
код цими двома рядками перевірки парності, що мають бути знайомі з наших попередніх обговорень цього
коду а для коду [7,4,3] Хеммінга ми можемо використати ці породжуючі елементи та ці рядки перевірки
парності до речі, тут усі наші рядки перевірки парності виявляються самі в коді
останній коментар про класичні лінійні коди, просто щоб пов'язати їх із формалізмом стабілізаторів: ці рядки перевірки парності
еквівалентні породжуючим елементам стабілізатора, де ми маємо лише Z та одиничну матрицю Паулі наприклад, рядки перевірки парності
110 і 011 для трибітного коду повторення відповідають точно породжуючим елементам стабілізатора ZZ⊗I
та I⊗ZZ і це узгоджується з нашим обговоренням спостережуваних такого типу з попереднього
уроку далі ми обговоримо CSS-коди, які є стабілізаторними кодами, що можна отримати шляхом об'єднання певних
пар класичних лінійних кодів з однаковою кількістю бітів у їх кодуваннях це не працює для будь-яких двох
класичних лінійних кодів два коди мають мати певне співвідношення, як ми побачимо незабаром, але тим не менш
ця конструкція відкриває безліч можливостей для квантових кодів виправлення помилок, що частково ґрунтуються на знаннях, здобутих за понад 75 років
класичної теорії кодування я вже згадував, що у формалізмі стабілізаторів породжуючі елементи стабілізатора,
що містять лише Z та одиничну матрицю Паулі, еквівалентні перевіркам парності наприклад, у трибітному
коді повторення ми можемо використати рядки перевірки парності 110 і 011, які забезпечують, що два лівих біти є
рівними і два правих біти є рівними для кожного рядка у коді і ці два рядки перевірки парності відповідають точно породжуючим елементам стабілізатора
ZZ⊗I та I⊗ZZ для коду [7,4,3] Хеммінга ми можемо використати
ці рядки перевірки парності і вони відповідають цим породжуючим елементам стабілізатора, де ми просто замінюємо кожну одиницю на Z, а кожен нуль на одиничну матрицю
можливо, ти впізнаєш ці породжуючі елементи стабілізатора, оскільки це три з шести породжуючих елементів стабілізатора для семикубітного коду Стіна це
звичайно не збіг, і ми незабаром побачимо, що саме тут відбувається ми дамо назву Z-
породжуючі елементи стабілізатора для таких породжуючих елементів, тобто вони містять лише матриці Паулі Z та одиничну матрицю в тензорних
множниках, тому X і Y ніколи не зустрічаються в Z-породжуючому елементі стабілізатора ми також можемо розглядати
породжуючі елементи стабілізатора, де зустрічаються лише X та одинична матриця Паулі, і ми можемо думати про такі породжуючі елементи як повністю аналогічні
Z-породжуючим елементам стабілізатора, за винятком того, що вони, по суті, описують перевірки парності у базисі «плюс-мінус», а не в
стандартному базисі наприклад, повертаючись до коду [7,4,3] Хеммінга, ми можемо розглянути
три інші породжуючі елементи стабілізатора з семикубітного коду Стіна, які слідують точно тому самому шаблону, що й для Z-породжуючих елементів стабілізатора для цього
коду, але цього разу ми підставляємо X замість одиниці, а не Z і те, що ми отримуємо лише з цих трьох породжуючих елементів стабілізатора
— це код, який включає 16 станів, показаних тут і які ми отримуємо, застосовуючи Hadamard gate до стандартних
базисних станів, що відповідають рядкам у коді [7,4,3] Хеммінга і звичайно, наш кодовий простір також включає
лінійні комбінації цих станів природно, породжуючі елементи стабілізатора такої форми називаються X-породжуючими елементами стабілізатора
отже, y та z цього разу не допускаються і тепер ми можемо визначити CSS-коди в
простих термінах CSS-коди — це стабілізаторні коди, що можуть бути виражені лише через Z-
породжуючі елементи стабілізатора та X-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора, тому y не допускається, і x та z не можуть з'являтися в одному породжуючому елементі стабілізатора
і просто щоб переконатися, що це зрозуміло, варто пам'ятати, що є свобода у виборі породжуючих елементів стабілізатора для стабілізаторних
кодів і це визначення говорить, що CSS-код — це той, для якого можливо вибрати лише Z та X
породжуючі елементи стабілізатора, але загалом можна вибрати інші породжуючі елементи стабілізатора, які можуть не бути Z або X породжуючими елементами стабілізатора, якщо захочеш
ось мабуть найпростіший нетривіальний приклад CSS-коду, де є і Z-породжуючий елемент стабілізатора
і X-породжуючий елемент стабілізатора, і перевірити це достатньо одним поглядом, адже ми вже знаємо з
попереднього уроку, що це правильний стабілізаторний код кодовий простір є одновимірним і є простором, натягнутим на
|Φ⁺⟩, і ми можемо переконатися, що наші два породжуючі елементи стабілізатора діють тривіально на цей вектор, розглянувши
два вирази ebit-а, показані на екрані, разом з інтерпретацією породжуючих елементів стабілізатора як перевірок парності у базисах 01
та «плюс-мінус» семикубітний код Стіна є ще одним прикладом CSS-коду, оскільки для цього
вибору породжуючих елементів ми маємо лише Z та X породжуючі елементи стабілізатора і знову ж таки ми вже знаємо, що це правильний
стабілізаторний код і дев'ятикубітний код Шора — ще один приклад цього разу ми маємо шість Z-
породжуючих елементів стабілізатора і лише два X-породжуючих елементи стабілізатора і це нормально, не потрібно балансу чи
симетрії між двома типами однак, критично важливо, щоб ми мали правильний стабілізаторний код, а це означає
що кожен із Z-породжуючих елементів стабілізатора повинен комутувати з кожним із X-породжуючих елементів стабілізатора, тому не можна
просто вибирати два типи породжуючих елементів незалежно і я скажу трохи більше про це пізніше в уроці далі ми обговоримо виявлення
та виправлення помилок для CSS-кодів і ми побачимо, що властивість, яку ми спостерігали для дев'ятикубітного коду Шора —
те, що ми можемо виявляти та виправляти X-помилки та Z-помилки незалежно — справедлива загалом для CSS-кодів
щоб пояснити це детальніше, розглянемо CSS-код, наприклад семикубітний код Стіна, але це може бути інший CSS-код якщо
WEBVTT
хочеш основна ідея полягає в тому, що Z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора виявляють X-помилки
але повністю ігнорують Z-помилки, оскільки Z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора завжди комутують із Z-
помилками крім того, Z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора також комутують із будь-якими Z gate, які ми можемо застосувати як
виправлення для Z-помилок аналогічно, X-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора виявляють Z-помилки, але повністю
ігнорують X-помилки та виправлення тому ми можемо, по суті, думати про Z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора як про представлення
класичного лінійного коду, що захищає від перевернень бітів, тобто X-помилок, тоді як X-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора
представляють класичний лінійний код у базисі «плюс-мінус», що повністю незалежно захищає від перевернень
між станами «плюс» та «мінус», тобто від помилок зміни фази або Z-помилок тому тепер цілком зрозуміло, що
відбувається з кодом Стіна: це просто код Хеммінга [7,4,3] для помилок перевернення бітів і код Хеммінга [7,4,3] для помилок зміни
фази ще раз: те, що Z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора та X-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора комутують, є обов'язковим —
це не був би правильний стабілізаторний код, якби вони цього не робили і можна сказати, що це вдача, що код Хеммінга [7,4,3]
працює таким чином, але є багато інших варіантів пар класичних лінійних кодів, що дадуть нам правильний стабілізаторний код
при такому об'єднанні тепер повертаючись до CSS-кодів загалом, припустімо, що Z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора
дозволяють виправляти до, скажімо, j X-помилок, а X-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора дозволяють виправляти до
k Z-помилок отже, у випадку коду Стіна j і k обидва дорівнюють одиниці, оскільки
код Хеммінга [7,4,3] може виправити одне перевернення біта, але загалом ці числа j і k можуть бути різними
тоді з дискретизації помилок випливає, що CSS-код може виправляти будь-яку помилку на кількості qubit-ів до
мінімуму j і k це тому, що коли ми вимірюємо синдром, довільна помилка на деякій
кількості qubit-ів ефективно коллапсується імовірнісно до деякої комбінації X-помилок, Z-помилок або обох, і тоді
X-помилки та Z-помилки можуть бути виявлені та виправлені незалежно отже, доки ми маємо два
класичних лінійних коди, що «ладять» у тому сенсі, що вони дають нам x та z породжуючі елементи стабілізатора, що комутують,
CSS-код, який ми отримуємо шляхом їх об'єднання, в основному успадковує властивості виправлення помилок обох кодів у сенсі, який я щойно
описав зауваж, що є ціна, яку треба платити: ми не можемо кодувати стільки qubit-ів, скільки бітів
у двох класичних кодах, оскільки загальна кількість породжуючих елементів стабілізатора для CSS-коду є сумою
кількостей перевірок парності для двох класичних кодів і кожен породжуючий елемент стабілізатора зменшує розмірність кодового простору
вдвічі наприклад, код Хеммінга [7,4,3] дозволяє кодувати чотири класичних біти, оскільки ми маємо лише
три перевірки парності для цього коду, тоді як семикубітний код Стіна кодує лише один qubit, оскільки він має шість
породжуючих елементів стабілізатора остання річ, яку я пояснюю про CSS-коди загалом у цьому уроці, стосується кодових просторів CSS-кодів
і того, як вони виглядають, і це також дасть нам можливість розглянути більш детально співвідношення, яке повинне виконуватись між
двома класичними лінійними кодами, щоб вони були сумісними в тому сенсі, що їх можна об'єднати для формування CSS-
коду розглянемо довільний CSS-код на N qubit-ах і нехай Z1 через Zs є n-бітними
рядками перевірки парності, що відповідають Z-породжуючим елементам стабілізатора це означає, що класичний
лінійний код, описаний Z-породжуючими елементами стабілізатора, який ми назвемо CZ, просто щоб допомогти нам пам'ятати, що це
код, що відповідає Z-породжуючим елементам стабілізатора, має форму, показану тут на екрані іншими словами, код містить кожен
рядок U, двійковий скалярний добуток якого з кожним із рядків перевірки парності дорівнює нулю якщо ми захочемо, ми також можемо
розглянути інший код, похідний від тих самих рядків, який ми назвемо DZ, і ідея тут полягає в тому, що ми розглядаємо
ці рядки Z1 через Zs не як рядки перевірки парності, а як породжуючі елементи
наразі незрозуміло, навіщо ми хотіли б думати про цей код, але можна і виявиться, що це буде важливо для цього
обговорення цей код називається дуальним кодом CZ і зазвичай позначається CZ⊥, тобто CZ з символом перпендикуляра
як надрядком, але ми будемо називати його DZ і це легко запам'ятати, оскільки D — це скорочення від
«dual» (дуальний) ми також можемо зробити щось подібне з X-породжуючими елементами стабілізатора, тому цього разу CX — це класичний лінійний код,
рядки перевірки парності якого відповідають X-породжуючим елементам стабілізатора, а DX — дуальний код цього коду до речі,
тепер ми можемо описати умови, які повинні виконуватись, щоб CZ і CX були сумісними в тому сенсі, що їх можна
об'єднати разом як CSS-код у термінах цих кодів, зокрема, повинно виконуватись, що
DZ міститься в CX або, що еквівалентно, DX міститься в CZ і тепер
можна описати кодовий простір CSS-коду, похідного від цих двох кодів, і один спосіб описати його полягає в тому, що
це простір, натягнутий на всі вектори, що мають форму, показану на екрані іншими словами, вони виглядають як рівномірні
суперпозиції над рядками дуального коду DX коду, що відповідає X-породжуючим елементам стабілізатора, зміщені
або піддані XOR з рядками коду CZ, що відповідає Z-породжуючим елементам стабілізатора, і ми побачимо, як це виглядає
у конкретному випадку коду Стіна трохи пізніше це має сенс, оскільки стани в кодовому просторі повинні бути
власними векторами зі значенням +1 для всіх породжуючих елементів стабілізатора, і зокрема множення на будь-який із X-
породжуючих елементів стабілізатора еквівалентно операції XOR з відповідним X-рядком, тому саме тому ці рівномірні суперпозиції
над DX, зміщеними різними рядками, виглядають ось так різні варіанти для зміщення
представлені рядком y у цьому виразі можуть давати той самий вектор до речі, тому ці стани не всі різні, але в сукупності вони натягують
весь кодовий простір тут є симетрія між x та z породжуючими елементами стабілізатора і
кодами, яким вони відповідають, тому ми можемо використати цю симетрію для опису векторів у кодовому просторі аналогічним способом, міняючи місцями x та z, але
нам також потрібно помінятись місцями стандартними базисами та базисами «плюс-мінус», саме тому операції Hadamard з'являються в цьому
виразі тепер для прикладу, що був обіцяний, тобто коду Стіна, ми отримуємо ці два закодовані стани як можливі
кодування нульового та одиничного стандартних базисних станів зокрема, ми можемо закодувати нульовий стан як рівномірну
суперпозицію над вісьмома рядками дуального коду [7,4,3] коду Хеммінга, що виявляється половиною рядків у коді [7,4,3] Хеммінга, і ми
можемо закодувати одиничний стан аналогічним чином, за винятком того, що всі рядки піддаються XOR з рядком із самих одиниць у цьому випадку
WEBVTT
оскільки цей рядок знаходиться в коді [7,4,3] Хеммінга, але не в його дуальному коді останній коментар тут: ми часто
насправді не дуже переймаємось тим, як виглядають вектори в наших кодових просторах, оскільки нам загалом не потрібно знати це для використання
кодів тому, якщо це пояснення було незрозумілим, насправді не варто надто хвилюватись про це, але це, звичайно,
природно запитати, як виглядають вектори в кодових просторах CSS-кодів і це опис надає відповідь на це
питання далі ми обговоримо конкретний CSS-код, відомий як торичний код, який є прикладом чогось відомого як
топологічний квантовий код виправлення помилок цей код був відкритий Алексієм Кітаєвим у
1997 році фактично, торичний код — це не окремий код, а сім'я кодів — один для кожного натурального числа не
меншого двох ці коди мають деякі ключові властивості перша ключова властивість полягає в тому,
що всі породжуючі елементи стабілізатора мають малу вагу як поліноміальні операції, зокрема всі вони матимуть
вагу чотири і це добре, оскільки означає, що кожне вимірювання породжуючого елемента стабілізатора не потребує залучення
занадто багатьох qubit-ів іноді люди говорять про квантові LDPC-коди або квантові коди з малою щільністю перевірок парності
і саме це означає цей термін, де в даному випадку «мало» означає чотири тому торичний код є прикладом
квантового LDPC-коду торичний код також має так звану геометричну локальність, що означає, що не
тільки породжуючі елементи стабілізатора мають малу вагу, але й можна розмістити qubit-и просторово так, що
кожне вимірювання породжуючого елемента стабілізатора залучає лише qubit-и, що знаходяться близько один від одного, що робить ці вимірювання легшими для реалізації на
практиці і нарешті, ці коди мають велику відстань, тому вони можуть терпіти відносно високий рівень
помилок ось як ці коди працюють спочатку нехай L — натуральне
число, не менше двох, і розглянемо решітку L×L з так званими
«граничними умовами, що є«, наприклад, ось решітка L×L для L=8 і зауваж, що лінії
праворуч і знизу є пунктирними, і ідея полягає в тому, що ми хочемо думати про пунктирну лінію праворуч як про ту саму лінію, що
й ліворуч, і аналогічно пунктирна лінія знизу є тою самою лінією, що й зверху
тому, якщо ми справді хотіли б реалізувати таку конфігурацію фізично, нам знадобилися б три
виміри зокрема, ми могли б утворити циліндр, спочатку з'єднавши ліву та праву сторони, а потім зігнути
циліндр так, щоб кола на кінцях — що колись були верхнім та нижнім краями решітки — зустрілися, або
можна спочатку з'єднати верх та низ, а потім сторони це працює в обох напрямках і не важливо, який спосіб вибрати для цього
обговорення те, що ми отримуємо, — це тор, або інакше кажучи, пончик, хоча уявляти його як камеру шини автомобіля
можливо краще, оскільки це не суцільне тіло — решітка фактично стала лише поверхнею
тора і саме звідси походить назва «торичний код» спосіб, яким можна пересуватись
тором, — якщо ти здатен переміщатись між суміжними точками решітки — ймовірно, буде знайомий людям, що грали в старі відеоігри
де, якщо ти виходиш за верхній край екрана, то з'являєшся знизу, і так само для лівого та правого країв
екрана і здебільшого саме так я буду описувати цю решітку, а не говорити конкретно про тор
у тривимірному просторі далі уявімо, що qubit-и
розміщені на ребрах решітки, як показано тут на екрані, де qubit-и позначені суцільними синіми
колами зауваж, до речі, що qubit-и, розміщені на пунктирних лініях, не є суцільними, і це тому, що ми вже представили ці qubit-и
або тими, що знаходяться зверху, або тими, що зліва, пам'ятаючи, що лінії зверху та зліва є точно тими самими лініями, що й ті,
позначені пунктирними лініями знизу та праворуч тому якщо ми підрахуємо всі ці qubit-и, ми отримаємо 2×L² qubit-ів і один
спосіб побачити це — зауважити, що ми отримуємо L² qubit-ів на горизонтальних ребрах і L² qubit-ів на вертикальних
ребрах отже, ось розміщення наших qubit-ів і щоб описати сам торичний код, нам просто потрібно описати породжуючі елементи стабілізатора
і вони бувають двох типів перший — це Z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора,
і вони відповідають плиткам або клітинкам у фігурі другий — це X-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора
і вони відповідають вершинам у фігурі наприклад, ось один
породжуючий елемент стабілізатора, тобто ми беремо тензорний добуток однієї операції Паулі Z для кожного qubit-а, що торкається цієї плитки, разом із одиничними матрицями
на всіх інших qubit-ах і це дає нам поліноміальну операцію ваги чотири ось приклад X-
породжуючого елемента стабілізатора, де матриці Паулі X діють на чотири qubit-и, суміжних з цією вершиною, разом із
одиничними матрицями на всіх інших qubit-ах тому знову це поліноміальна операція ваги чотири важливо, що для обох
типів породжуючих елементів стабілізатора ми включаємо ті, що обходять по колу на замкнених межах, і ось приклад X-породжуючого елемента стабілізатора,
що робить це тепер, щоб отримати правильний стабілізаторний код, нам потрібні породжуючі елементи стабілізатора,
що комутують Z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора всі комутують один з одним, оскільки Z комутує із самим собою, а одинична матриця
комутує з усім і так само для X-породжуючих елементів стабілізатора також зрозуміло, що Z-породжуючий елемент стабілізатора та X-
породжуючий елемент стабілізатора комутують, коли вони нетривіально діють на непересічних множинах qubit-ів, як для двох породжуючих елементів, що показані
тут решта можливість полягає в тому, що Z-породжуючий елемент стабілізатора та X-породжуючий елемент стабілізатора перекриваються і
щоразу, коли це відбувається, завжди є два qubit-и, на яких вони перекриваються, тому породжуючі елементи стабілізатора комутують, оскільки ZZ
та XX комутують тепер це не мінімальний набір породжуючих елементів стабілізатора зокрема, якщо ми перемножимо
всі Z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора разом, ми отримаємо одиничну матрицю, оскільки кожен qubit множиться на z двічі —
по одному разу для кожної плитки, що торкається qubit-а це означає, що перемноження всіх Z-породжуючих елементів стабілізатора разом
за винятком одного дає нам цей останній, тому вони не є незалежними, але якщо ми видалимо будь-який один із них, ми отримаємо
незалежний набір і те саме вірно для X-породжуючих елементів стабілізатора тому ми можемо видалити по одному кожного типу
і не має значення, які саме ми видалимо і це залишає L²−1 породжуючих елементів стабілізатора кожного типу щоб бути
точним, і це те, на що я натякав у попередньому уроці, ми насправді дбаємо про всі ці породжуючі елементи стабілізатора і в строго
операційному сенсі ми насправді не будемо вибирати один кожного типу для ігнорування, але для аналізу коду ми можемо
уявити, що один породжуючий елемент стабілізатора кожного типу був видалений, щоб ми отримали мінімальний породжуючий набір, пам'ятаючи
WEBVTT
що ми завжди могли б вивести результати цих видалених породжуючих елементів, розглядаючи їх як спостережувані, з результатів усіх інших породжуючих елементів стабілізатора
того ж типу тому кількість qubit-ів, що кодує цей код, дорівнює загальній кількості
qubit-ів, тобто 2×L², мінус загальна кількість породжуючих елементів стабілізатора в мінімальному породжуючому наборі, тобто 2×L²−
1, і це означає, що ми можемо кодувати 2 qubit-и я не аргументував, до речі, що кодовий простір є нетривіальним, але справді
він нетривіальний, і я залишаю тебе переконатись, що немає способу перемножити разом породжуючі елементи стабілізатора так, щоб ми отримали
−1 помножене на одиничну матрицю отже, це і є сам торичний код, і на цьому етапі може бути зовсім
незрозуміло, чому цей код повинен бути гарним для квантового виправлення помилок нам ще потрібно проаналізувати його і ми побачимо, що він є
справді дивовижним квантовим кодом виправлення помилок щоб зрозуміти, як торичний код функціонує як квантовий код виправлення
помилок, ми почнемо з розгляду різних помилок та синдромів, які вони генерують перша річ, яку варто зазначити, — це те, що
торичний код є CSS-кодом, оскільки всі наші породжуючі елементи стабілізатора є або Z, або X-породжуючими елементами стабілізатора
і це означає, що X-помилки та Z-помилки можуть бути виявлені та, можливо, виправлені
окремо і насправді є проста симетрія між Z та X-породжуючими елементами стабілізатора, що дозволяє нам аналізувати X-
помилки та Z-помилки фактично однаковим способом тому я зосереджусь на X-помилках, які можливо виявляються Z-
породжуючими елементами стабілізатора, і ти можеш перекласти все на Z-помилки, які можливо виявляються X-породжуючими елементами стабілізатора, використовуючи точно ті самі
ідеї ось фігура, що ілюструє наші два qubit-и на квадраті на ребрах решітки L×
L із замкненими межами і ми можемо уявити, що це розкладено на поверхні
тора наразі всі qubit-и сині, що вказує на те, що це qubit-и, на які не вплинули
помилки тому ти маєш уявляти, що на цьому етапі стан цих qubit-ів знаходиться в кодовому просторі для цього
коду як я вже згадував, ми зосередимося на X-помилках і за мить ми використаємо пурпурні кола для позначення qubit-ів, на які
вплинули X-помилки X-помилки виявляються Z-породжуючими елементами стабілізатора, які відповідають
плиткам у фігурі тому ми можемо дозволити білим плиткам позначати результати вимірювання +1, тобто записи
у синдромі, що відповідають цьому породжуючому елементу, тоді як сірі плитки позначатимуть результати вимірювання −1
ти можеш думати про результат +1, тобто білу плитку, як про вказівку, що відповідний
породжуючий елемент стабілізатора «щасливий» — все виглядає добре для цього породжуючого елемента тоді як результат −1, або сіра плитка,
вказує, що відповідний породжуючий елемент стабілізатора «нещасливий», оскільки, очевидно, мала місце помилка, що призвела до цього
результату тому наразі всі наші породжуючі елементи стабілізатора «щасливі», оскільки помилок не сталось тепер якщо ми подумаємо
про Z-породжуючий елемент стабілізатора, то він просто вимірює парність 4 qubit-ів, що торкаються плитки з
точки зору стандартного базису тому результат +1 не вказує, що на цих чотирьох qubit-ах не сталося X-помилок,
а радше вказує, що сталась парна кількість X-помилок, тоді як результат −1 вказує
що сталась непарна кількість X-помилок тому тепер давай введемо X-помилку та подивимось, що
відбувається два Z-породжуючих елементи стабілізатора, що відповідають плиткам, які торкаються цього qubit-а, тепер «нещасливі», оскільки ця
X-помилка антикомутує з обома цими породжуючими елементами або, що еквівалентно, з точки зору стандартного базису ми тепер у
стані, де обидва ці набори з чотирьох qubit-ів, що відповідають двом плиткам, мають непарну парність тому такий ефект від однієї
X-помилки отже, якби ми виміряли цей синдром і ми знали або припускали, що сталась лише одна X-помилка, ми б легко
визначили, який qubit перевернувся, і могли б просто перевернути його назад за допомогою X gate тепер подивимось, що відбувається
коли ми вводимо додаткові X-помилки і зокрема, подивимось, що відбувається, коли друга X-помилка виникає на іншому
qubit-і, що торкається одної з сірих плиток скажімо, сірої плитки зверху, ось так
ця плитка тепер «щаслива», оскільки на qubit-ах, що торкаються цієї плитки, сталось дві X-помилки, а два — парне число тому
ці дві X-помилки разом комутують із породжуючим елементом стабілізатора для цієї плитки інший спосіб сказати це:
ця друга X-помилка перевела всі стандартні базисні стани для цих чотирьох qubit-ів від непарної парності назад до парної
парності плитка зліва від цієї нової X-помилки, з іншого боку, тепер «нещаслива»
ми можемо продовжити цей процес додавання нових X-помилок і доки ми утворюємо ланцюжок суміжних X-помилок, де суміжні означає, що qubit-и торкаються
тієї самої плитки, ми ефективно пересуватимемо цей результат вимірювання −1 і ми виявляємо, що ми завжди маємо
результати вимірювання синдрому −1 на кінцях ланцюжків суміжних помилок тому ми завжди можемо виявляти ланцюжки
суміжних X-помилок доки вони мають кінці можуть, до речі, бути декілька ланцюжків, але ми повернемось
до цієї можливості пізніше однак, можливо, що ми маємо ланцюжок суміжних X-помилок, який
не має кінців, тобто наш ланцюжок помилок може утворювати замкнену петлю тому давай додамо ще кілька помилок так,
щоб вони утворили замкнену петлю, ось так наприклад, тепер ми маємо парну кількість X-
помилок на кожній плитці тому кожен породжуючий елемент стабілізатора тепер «щасливий» і ми виявили, що замкнені
петлі суміжних X-помилок не виявляються цим кодом, оскільки ми отримуємо весь синдром із +1 у такому
випадку це може здатись дещо розчаровуючим насправді нам потрібно лише чотири суміжних X-помилки, щоб утворити замкнену петлю,
і ми сподіваємось на щось краще, ніж код відстані 4 однак, деякі замкнені петлі
суміжних X-помилок самі є в стабілізаторі пам'ятай, що ми маємо X-породжуючий елемент стабілізатора для кожної вершини в
решітці і якщо ми перемножимо разом суміжні X-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора, ми можемо утворювати замкнені петлі X-
операцій, як ми маємо тут для замкненої петлі, яку ми побудували кілька хвилин тому тому деякі замкнені петлі X-помилок,
як та, що показана тут, насправді взагалі не є помилками, оскільки вони знаходяться в стабілізаторі, тому вони нічого не роблять із кодовим простором однак,
є деякі замкнені петлі X-помилок, що не знаходяться в стабілізаторі, і тому вони являють собою нетривіальні помилки, що
не виявляються кодом і є досить простий спосіб охарактеризувати різні типи
петель петлі, що перетинають кожну лінію в решітці — тобто кожну вертикальну лінію зверху вниз і кожну горизонтальну лінію
зліва направо — парну кількість разів, завжди є добутками X-породжуючих елементів стабілізатора це включає приклад,
показаний на екрані, а також петлі, що можуть бути набагато складнішими, включаючи можливість, що вони перетинають замкнені межі, але
WEBVTT
тим не менш, перемножуючи ці замкнені петлі X-помилок на X-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора, їх можна ефективно стиснути до
нічого і це, звичайно, вірно, що ми можемо отримувати лише такі петлі перемноженням разом X-породжуючих елементів стабілізатора, оскільки кожен X-породжуючий елемент стабілізатора
розміщує парну кількість X-операцій на кожній горизонтальній лінії та на кожній вертикальній
лінії інший тип замкненої петлі, яку ми можемо мати, — це та, що перетинає принаймні одну лінію непарну кількість разів, як
та, що показана тут, яка перетинає кожну горизонтальну лінію лише один раз і ось інший приклад, що перетинає
кожну вертикальну лінію лише один раз тому це приклади нетривіальних помилок, що не виявляються кодом, але ключ
тут полягає в тому, що єдиний спосіб утворити таку замкнену петлю — це обійти тор: або навколо отвору в
середині тора, або через отвір, або можливо обома способами це топологічна властивість,
що стосується тора — все зводиться до отворів — і саме тому це називається топологічним квантовим кодом виправлення
помилок у термінах цієї візуалізації двовимірної решітки із замкненими межами ланцюжок у цій категорії повинен
обходити одну або обидві замкнені межі таким чином, що унеможливлює стиснення цієї петлі до
точки шляхом перемноження на X-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора такий ланцюжок може бути більш
складним, ніж показаний тут, але це найкоротший з таких ланцюжків, оскільки він повинен якось обійти
одну або обидві замкнені межі і з цього випливає, що мінімальна вага нетривіальної
невиявленої помилки є L будь-яка замкнена петля з меншою кількістю помилок повинна потрапляти в першу категорію і тому
знаходиться в стабілізаторі а ланцюжки помилок, що не утворюють замкнених петель, виявляються кодом і це все — ось чому цей код
працює і в результаті ми отримуємо стабілізаторний код [[2L²,2,L]] ми використовуємо 2L²
qubit-ів для кодування 2 qubit-ів і код має відстань L далі я скажу зовсім небагато про
виправлення помилок за допомогою торичного коду, хоча не буду заглиблюватись у деталі якщо ми виміряємо синдром і
бачимо щось відмінне від синдрому «весь +1», де я говорю тут лише про Z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора,
то результати −1 вказують нам кінці одного або кількох ланцюжків суміжних X-помилок і ми можемо спробувати виправити
ці помилки, з'єднуючи результати −1 у пари та формуючи ланцюжок X-виправлень між ними і коли
ми робимо це, має сенс вибирати найкоротші шляхи для наших виправлень наприклад, якщо ми вимірюємо
синдром, подібний до показаного тут, то ми могли б вибрати цей шлях між «нещасливими» плитками та застосувати X
gate як виправлення вздовж цього шляху звичайно, фактичний ланцюжок помилок, що спричинив синдром, міг бути
іншим, як той, що показаний тут, але це нормально доки помилки та виправлення разом
потрапляють в стабілізатор також може статись, що наші виправлення утворюють петлю навколо
тора, що погано, оскільки тим самим ми спричинили б логічну помилку тому ця стратегія виправлення
вздовж найкоротших шляхів виправляє помилки малої ваги, але може не працювати для помилок більшої ваги але, звичайно, ми не можемо
очікувати більшого від будь-якого квантового коду виправлення помилок більш імовірно, мабуть, залежно від моделі шуму, що
ми спостерігатимемо купу −1 у синдромі і в цьому випадку ми можемо використовувати ефективні класичні алгоритми, щоб допомогти
нам об'єднати їх у пари та знайти помилку найменшої ваги, що представляє синдром як я згадував у попередньому
уроці, це може не завжди виправляти найбільш імовірне пояснення синдрому, але це добре працює загалом
і завжди успішно виправляє помилки, що мають вагу строго менше половини відстані L, і ще варто
згадати, що є інші стратегії, краще підходящі для різних моделей помилок минуло понад 25 років відтоді, як
торичний код був відкритий, і за цей час було проведено чималу роботу над квантовими кодами виправлення помилок, включаючи
інші топологічні квантові коди виправлення помилок, натхненні торичним кодом, а також коди, засновані на різних
ідеях я, звичайно, не можу надати тобі вичерпний список усіх відомих конструкцій кодів, але злегка торкнусь поверхні
і коротко згадаю кілька добре відомих прикладів по-перше, як виявляється,
насправді не є критичним, щоб торичний код мав замкнені межі, тобто можна вирізати лише частину торичного коду і
розгорнути її на плоскій двовимірній поверхні, а не на торі, і те, що ми отримуємо таким чином, називається поверхневим
кодом наприклад, якщо ми вирізаємо краї решітки за шаблоном, показаним тут із так званими «грубими» краями зверху
та знизу та «гладкими» краями з боків, і відповідно включаємо крайові випадки для породжуючих елементів стабілізатора,
то ми отримуємо код, що кодує лише один qubit цього разу, але код тим не менш успадковує найбільш
важливі характеристики торичного коду зокрема, нетривіальні невиявлені помилки для цього коду повинні
відповідати ланцюжкам помилок, що або простягаються від лівого краю до правого, або зверху до низу
залежно від того, є вони ланцюжками X-помилок або Z-помилок відповідно також можна вирізати
краї по діагоналі, щоб отримати те, що іноді називають «поверненими поверхневими кодами», і це може бути корисним для того, щоб зробити
коди більш економічними з точки зору кількості qubit-ів наприклад, якщо ми беремо цей поверхневий
код і відкидаємо деякі qubit-и, залишаючи квадрат, орієнтований по діагоналі, ми отримуємо інший поверхневий
код до тих пір, поки ми задаємо породжуючі елементи стабілізатора на межі правильним чином такі діаграми
корисні для пояснення, як визначаються породжуючі елементи стабілізатора, де чорні плитки, включаючи заокруглені на краях, позначають X-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора
а білі позначають Z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора ті, що на межі, до речі, є лише двокубітними XX-
або ZZ-породжуючими елементами стабілізатора цього разу і ти зазвичай будеш бачити ці діаграми, повернені на
45° ще один цікавий клас кодів, який також потрапляє в загальну категорію топологічних кодів, — це кольорові
коди я не буду пояснювати точно, як вони працюють, але один спосіб думати про них — це те, що вони є геометричними узагальненнями
семикубітного коду Стіна тож розглянемо семикубітний код Стіна і припустімо, що ми нумеруємо наші
qubit-и, використовуючи конвенцію упорядкування KCET, як показано тут на екрані потім ми можемо асоціювати ці сім
qubit-ів із вершинами графа, показаного тут і ми виявляємо, що породжуючі елементи стабілізатора відповідають
плиткам або граням, утворених ребрами графа і для кожної плитки ми завжди маємо Z-породжуючий елемент стабілізатора
та X-породжуючий елемент стабілізатора, що нетривіально діють саме на ті qubit-и, що знаходяться у вершинах цієї
WEBVTT
плитки це чудово, оскільки, як і для торичного коду, ми маємо геометричну локальність для цього коду, тому нам не потрібно
переміщати qubit-и на великі відстані для вимірювання породжуючих елементів стабілізатора і той факт, що Z та X-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора завжди нетривіально діють на
точно однакові набори qubit-ів, також чудово з причин, пов'язаних із квантовими обчисленнями, стійкими до збоїв, про що я
скажу більше в наступному уроці кольорові коди — це квантові коди виправлення помилок, що узагальнюють цей
основний шаблон, де ми, по суті, робимо те саме, але з іншими графами наприклад, ось граф із
19 вершинами, що підходить це дає нам код, що кодує 1 qubit у 19 і він має
відстань п'ять ці коди, до речі, називаються «кольоровими кодами», оскільки одна з необхідних умов на граф полягає в тому, що грані можуть бути тричі розфарбовані, тобто
ми можемо розфарбувати грані трьома кольорами і у насніколи не буде двох граней одного кольору, що мають спільне ребро
кольори насправді не мають значення для самого коду — у нас просто є x та z-породжуючі елементи стабілізатора для кожної грані незалежно від її кольору, але кольори
виявляються важливими для аналізу того, як він працює тому це дві дуже відомі
сім'ї кодів, але є багато інших відомих конструкцій, включаючи ті, що засновані на ідеях, подібних до цих сімей кодів, а також
цілком відмінних конкретний приклад квантового коду виправлення помилок, що нещодавно
був відкритий деякими з моїх колег в IBM, відомий як «gross code», який так названий тому, що gross — це дюжина
дюжин, або 144 зокрема, цей код кодує 12 qubit-ів у 144 qubit-и і має
відстань 12 я не буду пояснювати детально, як цей код працює він схожий на торичний код, за винятком того, що кожен із
породжуючих елементів стабілізатора тепер залучає два додаткових qubit-и, що знаходяться трохи далі він не має планарного вкладення
на відміну від поверхневого коду, але має так зване «bananer»-вкладення, тобто замість одного шару qubit-ів потрібно два
він належить до сімейства кодів, що називаються «bivariate bicycle codes», і що особливо примітно в них, це те, що
вони набагато ефективніші за торичний код або поверхневий код у тому сенсі, що можна кодувати набагато більше qubit-ів, тоді як вони
терплять приблизно однаковий рівень помилок для gross code додатково потрібні 144 qubit-и для вимірювання
синдрому, тому загальна кількість необхідних qubit-ів дорівнює 288, що робить його дуже перспективним кандидатом для сьогоднішніх
технологій і цим завершується цей урок, присвячений конструкціям квантових кодів виправлення помилок, включаючи CSS-коди, торичний код і
огляд інших конструкцій квантових кодів, включаючи поверхневі коди та кольорові коди сподіваюсь, ти приєднаєшся до мене на
наступному та останньому уроці серії, присвяченому квантовим обчисленням, стійким до збоїв, який розглядає виклик виконання
обчислень над закодованими квантовими станами за допомогою операцій та обчислювальних компонентів, що самі схильні до
помилок бувай до наступного разу